irgendetwas zieht ganze galaxien an
einen unbekannten ort am rande des
universums
es gibt eine krankheit die jeden
astronauten befällt und der weltraum hat
uns bereits angegriffen und soll es
wieder tun hier kommen passend zu
halloween fünf schaurige space fakten
bei denen selbst 610 um auch angst im
dunkeln bekommt nummer eins etwas bewegt
ganze galaxien aber wir wissen nicht was
und nicht wohin galaxien sind in
bewegung soweit nichts neues das liegt
unter anderem an der ausdehnung des
universums aber vor ein paar jahren hat
ein team der nasa etwas eigenartiges
gefunden ganze galaxien werden scheinbar
in eine bestimmte richtung außerhalb des
beobachtbaren teils des universums
gezogen wir wissen aber noch nicht so
richtig durch was und warum
forschende nennen das den dunklen fluss
den tag flow entdeckt wurde dieser durch
die sonne vemap die kosmische
hintergrundstrahlung ist was die damit
zu tun hat dass man auch heute noch dem
urknall von zu hause aus sehen kann
darüber haben wir schon in der ersten
folge von unglaubliche space fakten
gesprochen die könnt ihr euch hier
anschauen dadurch dass sich diese
galaxienhaufen bewegen wird die
kosmische hintergrundstrahlung verändert
woraus sich die richtung und
geschwindigkeit der bewegung messen
lässt die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler die den dark flow
gefunden haben wollen erklären dass sie
noch vor der kosmischen inflation also
der superschnellen expansion des
universums nach dem urknall gab es
bereiche des universums die heute schon
lange nicht mehr sichtbar sind und was
auch immer die galaxienhaufen anzieht
liegt genau dort dort wo wir nicht hin
sehen können und das ist ganz schön
gruselig aber es gibt immer noch ein
paar unklarheiten diverse forscherteams
haben verschiedene ergebnisse gefunden
die schwierig machen die frage zu
beantworten ob es den dark flow
tatsächlich gibt und wohin er fließt um
hier für klarheit zu sorgen bräuchte es
eine bessere karte des kosmischen
mikrowellenhintergrund
damit kann man mehr und präzise
berechnen wie sich galaxien hoffen
bewegen und vor allem wohin wenn es dem
dafür aber wirklich geben sollte dann
würden wir das erste mal den einfluss
von einer benachbarten region unseres
universums messen können nummer zwei der
welt raum hat uns angegriffen und er
wird es wieder tun wir schreiben dem
ersten september 1859 ritschard
carrington ein hobby-astronom schaut
tagsüber durch sein teleskop der himmel
ist blau alles soweit ganz normal doch
irgendetwas stimmt mit der sonne nicht
auf der oberfläche des sterns sind zwei
riesige flächen aus super hellem weiß im
licht fünf minuten später fehlt von
diesen flecken jede spur kurz nach
seiner entdeckung gefällt die gesamte
telegrafische verbindung auf der erde
aus die internationale kommunikation ist
tot kabel die alle telegrafen auf der
erde verbinden spucken funken papier
fängt feuer plötzlich sieht man über rom
kuba und howie polarlichter auch wenn
sich das so anhört das ist keine science
fiction story sondern das ist wirklich
so passiert und das war so etwas wie ein
angriff des weltraums auf die erde das
sagt zumindest das us-militär nur haben
uns eben keine aliens angegriffen
sondern das war der grösste magnetische
sturm den wir bisher auf der erde messen
konnten solche stürme entstehen wenn
sich in der sonne zu viel magnetische
energie anstaut wenn das ganze dann über
kocht wird die energie schlagartig
freigesetzt und hoch energetische
teilchen rasen auf die erde zu hier
angekommen schwächt so ein sturm das
erdmagnetfeld
das führt zu polarlichtern mitten in
europa und beschädigt auch
leistungstransformatoren das ergebnis
chaos und der zusammenbruch des
stromnetzes mit weitreichenden schäden
sollte es heute noch mal zu so einem
event kommen wie 1859 dann hätte das
noch krassere folgen für unseren hoch
technisierten alltags und die schlechte
nachricht ist rein statistisch sollte es
bald wieder soweit sein studien gehen
von einem sturm alle 500 jahre aus und
heutzutage müssen wir uns nicht nur um
telegrafen leitungen sorgen machen auf
ganzen kontinenten könnte der strom
ausfallen und in der erdumlaufbahn
würden durch die verformung der
atmosphäre hunderte satelliten zerstört
werden das heißt es gebe wieder gps noch
satellitenkommunikation noch bilder von
hubble deswegen würde ich die vorhersage
des weltraumwetters immer wichtiger aber
das carrington ereignis damals wie sich
nur acht minuten vorher sagen das ist
nicht viel zeit zur vorbereitung
und übrigens das gleiche wäre
ausgerechnet 2012 fast wieder passiert
denn da sind wir laut der nasa einem
ähnlichen solaren supersturm nur ganz
knapp entgangen wenn ihr jetzt noch mehr
darüber erfahren wollt dann könnt ihr
euch gerne dieses video von mir ansehen
da erkläre ich nochmal genauer was bei
solaren stimmen passieren kann und wie
wir die schlimmsten folgen verhindern
könnten wenn wir jetzt handeln und damit
kommen wir auch schon zum sponsor des
heutigen videos kleiner spoiler das
gerade war nicht das letzte mal dass wir
heute über die sonne reden und was sie
eigentlich für unsere vergangenheit
gegenwart und zukunft bedeutet um uns
dafür einen überblick zu verschaffen
haben wir blinkt ist benutzt da haben
wir uns das buch chasing the sun von
linda geldes in gerade mal zwölf minuten
erklären lassen denn im blinkt ist nimmt
ganze bücher und macht aus ihnen circa
15 minütige text und audio erklärer
unterteilt in sogenannte blinkx und hier
gibt es alles von philosophie und
psychologie bis hin zur ernährung und
physik insgesamt sind hier über 4.500
sachbücher und podcasts und ich mag
blinkt ist wirklich sehr gerne vor allem
wenn es darum geht schnell aber trotzdem
faktenbasiert in ein thema einzusteigen
dann ist das wahnsinnig praktisch
passend zu diesem video könnt ihr durch
auch zum beispiel dark matter and the
dinosaurs von lisa randall in nur 24
minuten durch lesen hier geht es um
unsere erde den weltraum und was das
alles mit dunkler materie zu tun hat
aber das beste kommt jetzt erst im
moment gibt es eine aktion extra für
euch auf linke.de / doktor watson
erhaltet ihr 25 prozent rabatt auf ein
jahres abo blinkt ist premium und falls
ihr euch noch nicht so ganz sicher sein
wollt ihr das wollt ihr das nicht ihr
könnt das ganze komplett kostenlos für
sieben tage lang testen klickt dazu
einfach unten auf den ersten blick in
der video beschreibung und fangt an zu
lernen danke an blinkt ist die
unterstützung bei diesem video hier und
mit genau dem geht es jetzt auch weiter
nummer drei schwerelosigkeit macht uns
krank und verändert unser aussehen
unsere körper sind quasi gebaut um mit
schwerkraft zu funktionieren wenn wir
aber schwerelosigkeit ausgesetzt sind
dann entspannt sich unser körper weil er
ja nicht mehr gegen die anziehung der
schwerkraft ankämpfen muss
das ist nicht nur unsere muskeln sondern
auch für unsere knochen eine große
entlastung das klingt ja erstmal
entspannt aber ist in diesem fall
überhaupt nicht gut wenn ich zum
beispiel monate lang auf der iss
herumspazieren dann müssen meine knochen
fast gar nichts mehr aushalten das sorgt
dafür dass calcium was in den knochen
gelagert ist erhöht ins blut gelangt das
wiederum führt dazu dass sich
knochenmasse verliere und mir so zum
beispiel schneller etwas berechnen kann
aber das ist nicht das einzige was mit
unserem körper im weltall passiert
während meine knochen in der
schwerelosigkeit immer dünner werden
schwebt mein gehirn in meinem schädel
das sorgt für mehr blutzirkulation und
dadurch sieht man ein kleines bisschen
verschwommen und wir sehen nicht nur
anders sondern wir sehen auch anders aus
unser körper hat auf der erde etwa fünf
liter wasser in den beinen die uns
helfen gegen die schwerkraft anzukämpfen
im weltraum funktioniert das natürlich
nicht das heißt die ganze flüssigkeit
schießt uns wortwörtlich in den kopf
während die beine dünner werden das
nennt man in der raumfahrt auch paffett
bird lex also aufgeblasener kopf und
vogel beine und wir haben noch gar nicht
über die psychischen folgen vom leben im
weltraum gesprochen alles ist eng einsam
und kommunikation zu den geliebten und
freunden auf der erde ist nicht immer
einfach mal eben spazierengehen ist
nicht möglich und so ein richtig frische
luft ist auch mangelware bonus fact was
uns außerhalb der einsamkeit und
isolation der raumstation erwartet
riecht nach schwarzpulver schwefel und
verbranntem metall
so haben zumindest astronautinnen und
astronauten den weltraum geruch
beschrieben vielleicht finden wir
irgendwann mal einen gigantischen raum r
frischer
wisst ihr gegen weltraum und so egal der
nächste feld kommt von einem
befreundeten youtuber nämlich entropie
auf seinem kanal findet ihr alles über
space quanten und den recht spannende
videos zum beispiel auch zum fermi
paradoxon dass ich empfehlen kann aber
jetzt erstmal viel spaß wird fakt nummer
vier die vernichtung des universums
durch den vakuum zerfallen es kommt in
der nacht oder am tag das spielt
eigentlich keine rolle wann es kommt
denn die welle der zerstörung über kommt
die erde wie ein tsunami mit der
geschwindigkeit des lichts um den vakuum
zerfall zu verstehen muss man das heks
feld betrachten dass unser universum
durchdringt doch das würde ich hier
meinen rahmen sprengen wichtig zu wissen
ist dass das heks welt verschiedene
stärken aufweisen kann die potenzial
genannt werden das heks potenzial
wiederum bestimmt zwei zuständigen
universum ein wahres vakuum oder ein
falsches vakuum ein wahres vakuum ist
der stabile zustand mit der niedrigsten
energie wie ein ball der in ein tal
stilllegt ein falsches vakuum ist so als
ob sich der ball in einer vertiefung in
der tal wand einnistet er sitzt ganz gut
doch ein kleiner stoß könnte es leicht
ins taumeln bringen unter ball würde ins
tal rollen ein universum im falschen
vakuum wird meter stabil genannt weil es
nicht aktiv zerfällt das gold nicht
runter aber es ist auch nicht gerade
stabil das große problem wenn man in
einem meter stabilen universum lebt
besteht darin dass man theoretisch einen
winzigen bereich des universums aus dem
falschen vakuum in das wahre vakuum
schubsen kann wenn man ein ereignis mit
ausreichend hoher energie erzeugt
wodurch eine blase aus waren vakuum
entsteht die sich dann mit
lichtgeschwindigkeit in alle richtungen
ausdehnt der zustand des wahren vakuums
könnte dem universum gefallen und wir
eine infektion würde sich dieser zustand
verbreiten die möglichkeit eines vakuum
zerfalls ist etwas was häufiger
diskutiert wird weil mesz um der masse
des higgs bosons darauf hindeuten dass
das vakuum tatsächlich meter stabil ist
es könnte bereits in einem weiten teil
des universums stattfinden und wir
würden nichts dagegen tun kann ok baut
das ist mir ganz gruselig entropie
vielen lieben dank für diesen super
spannenden space effekt wenn ihr euch
seinen kanal anschauen wollt dann findet
ihr einen link unten in der video
beschreibung und jetzt geht es weiter
mit nummer 5 die ganze sonne wird uns
ganz langsam bei lebendigem leibe kochen
ihr kennt bestimmt alle die schöne
geschichte vom frosch der langsam
lebendig gekocht wird weil das wasser so
langsam heiß wird dass er es nicht merkt
bevor es zu spät ist diese geschichte
ist mittlerweile widerlegt aber uns
menschen wird irgendwann genau das
passieren denn die erde wird immer
wärmer nicht nur durch uns menschen
sondern auch durch unsere sonne das
passiert zwar so langsam dass wir es
unmöglich spüren können ist aber
unaufhaltsam und während der frosch wenn
das wasser zu heiß wird herausspringen
kann müssen wir da auf der erde ein
bisschen kreativer werden langfristig
wird so das gesamte leben auf der erde
ausgelöscht forschende gehen davon aus
dass die sonne alle eine milliarde jahre
6 prozent heller wird das hört sich
jetzt erstmal nicht nach besonders viel
an und auch nichts was uns irgendwie
besorgen sollte aber nach aktuellen
berechnungen braucht es nur 1,1
milliarden jahre bis die erde dadurch zu
heiß für leben wird zugegeben
wahrscheinlich kommen wir menschen da
der sonne zuvor aber was wir selbst mit
super viel treibhausgasen nicht schaffen
würden ist es unsere ozeane zum kochen
zu bringen denn das kann die sonne und
das ist wie es aussieht auch schon auf
der venus passiert in 3,5 milliarden
jahren wird die sonne 40 prozent heller
sein und so alles an wasser auf der erde
zum kochen bringen sollten bis dahin
menschen überlebt haben man sieht es
nicht gut für sie aus denn dann ja wir
bestehen zu 60 bis 75 prozent aus wasser
was das dann bedeutet das könnt ihr euch
wahrscheinlich vorstellen
und wenn dann alle ozeane von der sonne
weg gekocht wurden geht es erst richtig
los denn irgendwann wird unserer sonne
der wasserstoff ausgehen die angestaute
helium asche des sterns wird instabil
und unter dem eigenen gewicht
zusammenbrechen die sonne wird zu einem
roten giganten das wird so ein zirka 5,4
milliarden jahren passieren der kern der
sonne wird immer heißer und dichter dh
die sonne würde wachsen sie würde so
groß werden dass sie mindestens den
orbit von merkur und venus und
vielleicht sogar den orbit von uns
erreichen wird und wenn menschen es
irgendwie schaffen sollten kochende
ozeane zu überleben wäre allerspätestens
dann zappenduster beziehungsweise es
habe ein superheld es sei denn dass sich
der orbit der erde mit der ausbreitenden
sonne verändert also drücken wir mal die
daumen aber eigentlich ist klar
irgendwann müssen wir unseren planeten
verlassen wenn wir überleben wollen
das war die dritte folge von fünf space
backen dieses mal ein kleines special zu
halloween die halloween in den ersten
beiden folgen haben wir unter anderem
darüber gesprochen dass die sonne nicht
nur heller wird sondern auch noch
unglaublich laut ist das könnt ihr euch
hier anschauen und die erste folge von
den film space fakten gibt es hier
ansonsten vergessen ich den kanal hier
kostenlos abonnieren checkt entropie aus
und bis zum nächsten mal bleibt
neugierig
[Gelächter]
[Musik]